- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy
which you probably know
is a not-for-profit
with a mission of providing
a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere.
And not for profit means
no one owns Khan Academy,
we are a public charity.
You own as much of Khan Academy as I do.
It's there for the public good.
And the way that we're able
to provide this service, the videos,
the software, the exercises for free
to tens of millions of
learners around the world is
because of philanthropic donations
from generous folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
As you probably know, in 2020
the world leaned more heavily
on Khan Academy than ever before
to keep the learning
going during the pandemic.
We had 12 billion learning minutes
on the platform last year.
6 billion students coming on their own.
6 billion is hundreds of thousands
of teachers getting
their students to do it
as part of the distance
learning classroom experience
during the pandemic.
And as now we get, hopefully, to the light
at the end of the tunnel on the pandemic
and hopefully over the next couple
of months things are able to normalize,
it's even more important
that we don't let up
because when all of the
stuff has been thrown up
into the air, we, one, need to make sure
that as it falls things don't break.
Students have accrued
gaps in their learning.
Teachers need more support,
families need more support.
And also there's a unique
window of time right now,
over the next six to 12 months,
where as things come back
to earth, not only should they not break
but there's an opportunity to make sure
that the post-pandemic
world could even be better
than the pre-pandemic world.
A world where every student
is able to fill in their gaps,
learn at their own time and space
and really reach whatever
that potential is,
that every teacher has
the tools to personalize
for their students and
feels optimally informed
and optimally empowered
and every parent feels
like there are resources
regardless of your zip code,
regardless of your income
where your children can
reach their potential.
So I hope you can consider
making a donation.
In particular, we're hoping
to get at least 12,000
new donors of any level.
Any donation makes a huge difference
to become part of this mission
to provide a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere.